what was inspiring you as you were
writing this song and the story that you
wanted to tell just kind of like what
it's been like
in my late teens and early 20s kind of
kind of falling in and out of love and
the ups and downs of that you're on the
ground crying in the bathroom floor and
then you'll
have feelings for another person again
you never know what's around the corner
bomb bomb dropped just four months after
camilla and sean mendes called it quits
now we can't say the single is for sure
about their split after two years of
dating but the lyrics kind of suggest it
is that i love you for life but i just
sold the house can you talk about like
who or what in your life has kind of
helped you through those times when you
needed to get back on your feet
one my therapist
two
uh my friends and my family it's been a
hell of a year thank god we made it out
what was it like reuniting with ed for
this track we were kind of writing and
brainstorming back and forth on
instagram you just reminded me that you
probably had to dm him because he
doesn't have a real phone right so you
couldn't like text him
couldn't text him it was all instagram
he was like instagram dm or email
camila and ed's bilingual song is the
latest hit on her new album familia out
this friday a lot of people have told me
like
this feels different than your other
albums and in the sense that it feels
more grounded it feels more honest
[Music]
we love that you collaborated with ed
what about another bestie taylor swift i
mean i would love that whenever she's
down i'm down